Jane Fonda snaps back at megyn kelly
after she asks about plastic surgery we
really want to talk on Wednesday the 79
year old actress stopped by megan kelly
today with her longtime friend robert
redford to promote their new netflix
film our souls at night but things got
uncomfortable when the former Fox News
anchor asked Jane about going under the
night I read that you said you felt
you're not proud to admit you've had
work done why not we really want to talk
about still the Grace and Frankie start
up the moment in stride and danced
around the subject one of the things
people think about when they look on you
is how amazing you look well thanks good
attitude good posture take care of
myself
but let me tell you why I love this
movie that we did our shows at night
[Laughter]
hashtag awkward and in case you are
wondering what Kelly was referencing
back in 2015
Jane told W Magazine quote I did have
plastic surgery I'm not proud of the
fact that I've had it I was taught to
think that if I wanted to be loved I had
to be thin and pretty that leads to a
lot of trouble
[Music]
you